la crise frappe de plein fouet les
restaurants et un grand nombre d'entre
eux ne pourront jamais rouvrir un
sondage réalisé par le regroupement
restaurants canada révèle que trois
propriétaires sur quatre sont très ou
extrêmement préoccupés par leur niveau
d'endettement et un restaurateur sur
deux craint de devoir fermer
définitivement ses portes
si les conditions ne s'améliorent pas
d'ici trois mois avec nous deux chefs et
restaurateurs reconnu graziella battista
chef et propriétaire du restaurant
graziella et jérôme ferrer propriétaire
de la boîte du chef du restaurant
europea et grand chef relais châteaux à
vous deux bonsoir mon changer quand on
dit qu'un restaurateur sur deux pourrait
fermer ça donne un peu le vertige je
vous dirais je demande simplement leur
comment allez-vous graziella d'abord
écouté je suis très inquiète que vous la
réalise je pense que ce sera la réalité
en restant sur deux va fermer vous savez
nos domaines la restauration travaille
sur une marge de profits très très
minces et de envisagée de leur demande
et surtout les tout petits restaurants
qui ont peut-être 24 ans table de
travail et à 50%
c'est inimaginable je vois difficilement
comment ils vont s'en sortir
je suis ici dans un emplacement qui me
permet d'étaler mais table à distance
sur trois étages c'est pas tout le monde
qui a cette possibilité
c'est extrêmement inquiétant s'il n'ya
pas s'il n'y a pas un programme qui mis
en place avec plus substantielle pour
notre industrie
c'est grave jérôme ferrer comment allez
vous mais je vais dire bien j'essaye de
garder le moral de rester positif comme
graziella le disait toute la
restauration aujourd'hui j'ai une pensée
particulière pour mes consoeurs mes
confrères c'est un drame
sincèrement il faut s'attendre dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois si la
situation continue
un effort romain mais complet total de
la scène culinaire de montréal attendez
vous à ça je tiens à dire avant tout
qu'un restaurant ce n'est pas juste une
business c'est un patrimoine culturel
c'est un patrimoine culinaire d'un
peuple d'une nation
on est les ambassadeurs d'artisans de
producteurs ce qui me fait peur parce
que je suis juif moi-même d'artisans
producteurs j'ai grandi dans un petit
village de 80 habitants dans le sud de
la france où mon père était vigneron et
agriculteurs quand la restauration va
plonger c'est tout un univers agricole
qui en même temps ça c'est terrible
cette série est ce que c'était fatalité
est ce que c'est une fatalité est ce
qu'on s'en va véritablement vers une
disparition de plusieurs restaurants où
il ya une manière d'un dans le contexte
actuel de se réinventer de rester vivant
claude viallat bensouda
écoutez je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix
c'est c'est ce qu'on a fait dès le
premier jour quand on a annoncé la
fermeture des salles à manger un très
rapidement il a fallu accepter la
situation s adapter à cette réalité et
rapidement on a mis en place des plats à
emporter
pour moi ce n'était pas envisageable de
fermer totalement ma salle à manger
quand on nous a dit qu'on était
considérée essentielle dans la tou mis
en place
mais ça donne une idée de ces portions
de votre chiffre d'affaires je présume
une petite mais on n'est qu'à 15 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires
on a salle à manger on a aussi des
salles de réunion alors on a énormément
de groupes
tout ça en 24 heures a été annulée et
pour nous c'est un produit a en
parallèle à la restauration qui se
chiffre à peu près à 30% de notre
chiffre d'affaires alors ça c'est
disparu à 24 heures et cette nouvelle
réalité bien il fallait absolument la
mettre en place avec tout le protocole
que ça prend la sécurité et tout et on a
envoyé rapidement menu d'emprunt pour
emporter à tous nos clients
on a mis ça sur les réseaux sociaux on a
une réaction assez impressionnante ça me
touche énormément que nos clients
viennent nous soutenir
et c'est grâce à eux qu'on ait connu on
arrive à à peine arrivé au seuil de
rentabilité je suis même pas certaine
qu'on est là oui je le soutiens jérôme
ferrer est ce que le soutien le soutien
des gens et là est ce que soutient de
l'état est suffisant ou non je peux pas
dire que les mesures ne sont pas
exceptionnels bien sûr qu'ils vont
l'être les mesures avaient les 75%
il faut comprendre qu'une chose les
restaurants sont à l'arrêt donc 75 % ne
s'en tient pas à grand chose pour
l'instant personne salariale de 75 pour
ça dans mon exemple un mois comme de
nombreux confrères en restauration
la masse salariale explose chez nous
parce que c'est la rénumération au
service ou pourboire
donc on n'a même pas droit au prêt est
de toute manière les crises ça reste un
poison c'est pas ça qui va nous aider à
tenir le choc à tenir le coup fait quoi
si il faut comprendre que la
restauration a changé de visage
immédiatement à l'espace de 24 heures on
a dû tout réapprendre à se réorganiser
mais au-delà de tout ça à se réinventer
dans l'urgence de la situation
pour ma part j'ai misé que sur une chose
moi je suis dans un cas de figure un
petit peu à part dans la haute
gastronomie la haute gastronomie ne peut
pas se faire à emporter et ses trains de
cuisinier mois au quotidien donc j'ai
préféré privilégier une voie en me
disant pour twitter parce que ça risque
de durer
des mois de travail et dans l'économie
d'échelle alors avec mon équipe
même les sommeliers les serveurs les
runner les maîtres d'hôtel tout le monde
en a créé des boîtes ou un autre pour
vous dire 55 dollar une semaine de repas
par personne avec cinq repas de la
semaine
il n'y a même pas de bénéficier même pas
de profit parce qu'une fois latif raison
de payer il n'y a plus rien c'est pas il
faut qu'on passe le temps et là le
gouvernement pourrait nous aider
pourrait faire la différence
un exemple à en france en europe les
restaurateurs ont le droit
d'établissement ont le droit de vendre
du vin sans l'achat de produits
alimentaires
je pense que il devrait y avoir des
mesures même si elles sont temporaires
pour nous permettre de passer ce cas
est-ce que vous avez confiance graziella
espoirs de traverser la crise de
reprendre vos activités normalement
éventuellement je j'ai grand espoir
je suis une optimiste je reste toujours
positif
ah je pense que on doit beaucoup on doit
travailler très très fort comme dit
jérôme on ne peut pas se permettre de
faire des plats à emporter avec de la
peau de cuisine alors on s'est adapté à
d'autres produits qui sont justement
autant intéressant mais il faut faire
attention il faut pas non plus rentrer
dans ce dans ce rythme de dire ok on
fait pour emporter on va faire livrer
parce que je fais l'exercice de
d'évaluer si je pouvais prendre faire
livrer par des compagnies ou britz et
foudroie et ensuite suite mais ils
chargent des 25 à 30% de du montant de
la transaction alors ça ne vaut pas la
peine c'est qu'on perd encore plus que
ce qu'on est en train de perdre
actuellement ce n'est pas évident il
faut juste faire très attention à ça à
ses dépenses je pense qu'un programme
dead est essentielle oui pas juste du
gouvernement je pense que dans d'autres
sphères que ce soit hydro québec que ce
soit gaz métro que ce soit le taux de
taxes
et parce que les factures continuent à
arriver quand on nous a fermé le 15 mai
mars mais il y avait toute une machine
d'avant ça qui était en marche et alors
toutes ses factures la tire bien sûr et
et voilà j'ai espoir bien le viala je
vous souhaite bonne chance je dois vous
arrêter là je vous souhaite bonne chance
on pense à vous bien sûr on continue de
suivre de près les soutiens qui sont
annoncés jérôme ferrer graziella
battista merci beaucoup rire vaut rire
avec nous merci à vous